foreign
[Music]
I'm still I'm still afraid to admit
which way I wipe
what you mean
you'd be wiping towards the ball I mean
I don't know are you [__] serious
what that's great you what you wipe
towards your balls I don't think so
anyway man so I use
um
I use I use wet wipes I don't know I
mean they should have people like kind
of like that should be something you
have to like instead of like your gender
like say which way you wipe like that
way people can just assume your gender
right there I get it I guess I don't
know but I never heard about I've never
heard of a man wiping towards his balls
yeah that's insane I think that'd be who
would do it you know nobody I know yeah
anyway there will be so much opportunity
for you when we're talking before about
having kids you have your kid you have
to make the choice do you want to miss
things in your kid's life or do you want
to take the opportunity and I think
there's a balance there yeah you're
gonna have to strike Dusty slay told me
something not necessarily about the kids
in general but he says there's people
who like comedy is their life and then
there's people who comedy is their job
and I think I'd rather be my job yes
because yeah you have to be like in
Japan they have a high suicide rate
because they do so much comedy yeah yeah
this is too funny yeah I have a problem
with cleaning ladies
but you know also I have a problem with
what the emerge the people that call the
911 what do you call it dispatch people
dispatch people the people that like
help save people's lives now if you
watch any like podcasts about murders
and stuff and you hear dispatchers yeah
it's like they don't they're like the
most insane people on Earth it's like
um
my husband was just stabbed to death
he's still in the house right I'm in the
closet
um calm down yeah calm down [__]
my husband's dead like you know I mean I
can't hear you speak clearly yeah you
know what I mean but they're they're
trained to try to calm you down they're
trying to reverse no no no no no no I
don't want them to freak out no I don't
want the freak out it's like are you
call me and you're panicking
I want to be real okay all right I'm the
dispatcher guy okay all right call me
yes
my wife my wife just stabbed everyone in
our neighborhood she's coming to kill me
please help help I already got the cops
coming poop
it's simple as that that's good the cops
are coming but you need to stay on the
phone no no no what am I gonna do you
need to gather information no I want her
to knock if you're hiding you shouldn't
be talking on the phone [__] all right
you call me then here we go all right
ring ring
it always takes a minute all right ring
ring
ring ring uh 911 dispatch I can help you
my whole family's Dead
[Music]
who did it
are you okay are you hurt
he still in the house my two kids are
slaughtered oh is he close to where your
kids are indeed they're dead oh they're
all dead well that's okay call the cops
because I
okay well then you should quiet down a
little bit huh that's how they are yeah
they are like that I don't like it well
I think it's with she's busy man she's
heard this hook all day all day she gets
these calls
she's sick of this gets somebody else on
there all right this is what you would
rather prefer ready go ahead call Ling
ring 911 dispatch yeah
um somebody's in the house oh my God
they're how do they get in the [__]
house
holy [__] how do they get into the
[__] house what the [__] what did you
do what did you do
that's not what I want
I would love to rob a bank but I want to
do it I want to do it to a bank that's
[__] people over like Wells Fargo
remember they got in trouble for [__]
everybody over come on man can we clip
them
I have the voice for it dude you do have
a bank get the [__] down on the ground
you don't know who we are you don't know
what we're capable of amazing don't look
at me [__] I'll end you everyone
put your phones out put them on the
ground but I'll be holding up a sign
that says hey we used to be Comics we're
definitely not going to hurt anybody say
that you don't say that
hey Andrew is this funny uh like laying
on the ground is cool
the [__] ground you stupid [__] is
it funny if I go like
laying on the ground is cool when you're
having sex
not you know what never mind never mind
totally safe so many women white women
have looked at my dick
right right and they went yeah no
no no no there we go they would always
go oh it's not as small as I imagine
right right right that always you know I
mean that always kind of throws me
forever it should make you feel kind of
good A little good
if it was like the opposite like oh it's
smaller than I imagine yeah right then
yeah is that why you take it out so much
you're proud of it
yeah yeah
you see the brilliant comedic typing on
that yeah I mean you can't you're born
with that General meetings make they're
they're insane yeah well it's I don't
need them anymore it's just a thing it's
nice when you're brand new and no one
knows who you are at all yeah it feels
nice but this way you had no she had
never she was I was like yeah I did a
sketch show and she was like what
I was hoping you might have heard of it
before we had a meeting key and peel
yeah
I actually write that show I'm black I'm
one of the guys
[Laughter]
send a representative I think I'm gonna
send a representative and then sit like
two tables over and just over here and
then towards the end go
I couldn't help but over here
and I'll go
[Laughter]
it's the best it's a high-speed
lifestyle dude running out of a running
out of a restaurant is [__] so funny
dude I mean what is the speed limit for
people
what even is it dude a fast walk is nuts
what about a four speed walking I ran to
the [__] smoothie place last week
they gave me the wrong order and I was
like well I don't want the guys waiting
on me and I [__] booked it there and
then back I kind of I kind of get a
little slower with this smoothie guest
out but yeah dude that's crazy you did
that that's very weird ripping it well
it's like why not who's who's a dictate
the speed for everybody
let's move you you think we should
introduce running pick up the pace so we
all finished a meal pay for it stand up
before jackets on we say no you don't
get anything it was good to see you
my Uber is actually here right now you
don't want to get in digestion dude
knock yourself over and Sprint
we're gonna Sprint into the restaurant
you're so [__] pretty like you're
like that's normally when you meet like
an actress or something you see on TV or
like I know for a fact I that uh I've
seen people on TV this is gonna sound
weird but back in the day I've seen
people on TV hung out with them hooked
up with them and then you find them to
be a [__] mess top to bottom their
eyes are puffy and everything you're
you're really uh very pretty you have no
[__] bags under your eyes you have
great skin your hair is like [__] uh
your hair is like smell like you're just
like taking a jab at me I mean like I'm
working on these bags
you have you do look tired you're
jealous you're healthy and he's he's fat
one of my like Fondest Memories was
getting [__] by a fat man while he was
eating a pizza and then I was eating the
pizza too
you know
see you soon
now we're having sex because I throw up
my throat when I sleep oh my gosh you're
gonna throw that up you hey Tony he
looked like he uh do that thumb trick in
front of kids you know what they thought
about yeah
[Laughter]
hey y'all want to see something cool
thank you David thank you David uh every
time I watch you which is never
um I just I get more each time and
tonight you reminded me of a Malcolm X
who didn't give a [__] anymore and you
dress like you collect paintings [__]
shut your ass
come on
well if I got a room with nothing but
pottery and weird-ass painters you're
just sitting there smoking cigar and
admire them
yeah it's like 1.5 million in this room
I know you drop a old Volkswagen Beetle
with that hat
that hat look like it came with a card
trick [__] you ever played three card
money pick out the queen I'll give you
twenty dollars
[Applause]
that [__] like he do midnight stock at
Target
he dressed like he used to hang out with
Tony Hawk
I'm the one that showed that you get a
360 kick flip
[Laughter]
let's see what you got to say [__] like
Mrs Doubtfire [__]
Robin Williams
you look like the daddy from Beethoven
[__] your ass
you better name him something because
when he turns my house up I gotta call
him something
David I loved you on that TV show my 600
pound life
[Applause]
actually you should audition for that
but you probably have to lose a couple
pounds
hey David forget about stand up do a
[__] sit-up
oh [__] I remember my first hangover was
after one of the mountain Trashmore
events oh okay very yeah
um but only because we had to get up
early we had to get up like 6 a.m to
catch our flight home did you drink in
front of people
uh what this is a legit question we went
to another story yes I did we went to
house party so people saw you yeah I was
like 18. yeah
yeah but I do remember that feeling like
this sucks that's amazing this is the
worst that I'd like do I have the flu I
couldn't figure it out it was terrible
yeah I wish I had that feeling I I don't
know I pushed through that I felt great
yeah but do you so so how did how does
Tony Hawk let loose uh I mean skating
has always been my escape and my my
expression so but it has been after that
you don't just like sit around jerk off
in the park or something
I wish man right wave down a couple of
homeless guys hey look at this
it's living let me tell you something
jerk okay now like I said five years I
came into my life I still if you buy the
wrong jerky you're like what am I doing
here I mean it's just you you have to
grind you're incisors same thing with
trail mix but go ahead
you buy the wrong trail mix it has like
an almost chemical taste to it where
there's like you're like this is not
something's wrong here okay let's let's
just so the jerk well jerky can have a
little bit of a weird taste too okay
that doesn't need to be refrigerated
yeah that is something's wrong and then
you open it open up and they got that
packet in there of chemicals yeah
because they're like God forbid the same
packet that you only the only other
place you find it is in your suitcase
yeah you find it in your goddamn luggage
it's like literal chemicals and they're
like we need these chemicals in here so
that the chemicals and not stay as fresh
chemicals
and then also it's like first of all
okay first of all like orange juice and
greeting cards I don't know where the
jerky people have the balls of hitting
the price tags they do with the jerky
what are you talking about bottom line
jerky is 5.99 dude 7.99 a bottom line
jerky you're getting a high-end jerky
you're going 11.99 129 if you're in the
air Dave if you're in the airport with a
top-line jerk you can't you can't
airport us here you can't airport it but
I will say I will say I will say I will
say 99 for razors in the airport
the dichotomy I thought you know where I
find jerky in gas station truck stops
and at the airport is where I buy my
jerky the most okay and so I'm looking
at the same jerky I'm looking I'm paying
14.99 but I'm telling you something hold
on a second hold on a second let's call
the median price on jerky 9.99 and I
think I'm the medium I think I'm being
liberal but I agree let's say nine let's
call it 9.99
but it's a bag of steak how much do you
want it to cost I mean you're buying a
bag of steak let me come in right there
you're not buying a bag of steak just
because it's in a bag doesn't mean
you're buying a bag of steak because my
other gripe with jerky is after you open
that and you peel and you pop in there
there's four and a half pieces of jerky
in there it's 9.99 nah dude you got to
be honest with me right jerky bags I
never plump they never ample you open
that [__] up you take a couple of bites
especially if they're bigger pieces and
you look back in you're like oh my God I
got a ration this shirt I gotta be
honest with you I fine you have to
ration just I I disagree I find that
that jerky bag offers me a a wealth of
jerky way more than I can ever finish in
one sitting oh Joe I'm dead serious
I'll give you it when it's when it's
truthful but you you my problem with
little jerky goes a long way my problem
with jerky is that you're not getting a
second helping out of jerky you're not
unless you're buying a mother lode bag
I'm
[Music]
that was good nothing it was good
nothing I mean I think you're giving a
little too much credit I think all right
Jesus
if I did that on stage if I went do you
ever buy Jack Links it's all the house
down no I've never done it but I have it
Jerry Stiller would have loved it when
you find out you're not getting out
you're not bailing out you're not taking
the deal so they're not kicking you out
yeah that's when you get sent to like
what would be Rikers which is long-term
County jail holding right so I'm I'm at
the Portland equivalent of Rikers okay
and I was in there for like eight months
and you know fighting my case fighting
inmates yeah all that [__] yeah yeah
some video where you said I didn't see
sunlight for eight months I'm like bro
you're from Portland
you were built for this dog were you
early on AIM too because I talked about
this with somebody recently but I used
to go AOL and semester I used to go into
the chat rooms like At first I was like
in basketball interest and talking I was
like wrestling and stuff like that and
then I would go into like divorce or sex
or whatever and I'd be talking to who I
assumed were divorced women but probably
some sort of old guy and like talking
about how to spice up their marriage and
like what how old are you I'm like 11.
holy at my grandpa
dude I'm at like my grandparents one
computer in their living room looking
over my back as my grandpa's watching
the Giants and I'm like you know talking
to me you're 11 years old trying to tell
tell some lady how to spice up her
marriage yes your husband like roller
coasters
yeah
what the [__] man Dolores you gotta get
the Magic Bag
you need to go to Action Park lady I
said to my wife I said I said when we
get married I said if you're not
pregnant by the time I'm 45 I'm not
doing it because after that I'm not
doing it oh wow and now I've had the
vasectomy oh so it's tied up I've I well
it's snipped or whatever does [__] come
out or no comes see this is funny
because my father man I'm curious this
isn't my new special coming out February
14th um but my my father I sold him I
said I'm getting a vasectomy and he said
oh don't do it and I said why and he
said because most women not all women
they like to see the [__]
that's what he said yeah yeah I said Dad
when you have vasectomy you still
ejaculate it just doesn't work anymore
and he went oh get one then
really well what happens is so they snip
it I got I paid to get knocked out most
people just do it with laughing gas
these days and the guy gives you a
certificate like you're a child
like you've been like I don't I don't
imagine they do that when women get
their tubes tied I don't think they'd be
that Patrick but for men they're just
like this should I got a certificate
right so so the guy cuts it and then
you've got to uh do you've got to have
30 wanks I thought it was fifth well my
guy only asked for 30. what's away wow
you got to clear out you gotta come 30
times oh that's how Australia is called
jerking off wink yeah okay yeah yeah so
you've got to do 30 loads and then
you've got to send him your 31st load to
make sure that vasectomy worked because
you've cleared out of the balls of any
active semen as I was leaving he went oh
by the way the record's 19 days
wow and I was like I can do that e
well this is the problem the first seven
days you don't want to touch it
because there's still a stitch there and
stuff you don't want to be pulling
against the Stitch so that takes away a
lot of your wank days oh I see the uh
yeah yeah
so if he said
so that gave him 12 days to get rid of
30 wanks uh yes yes
I see what the mouth yeah yeah yeah so
if you how do you mean how many wings
would you need to do then what about
three three three a day wow and I
haven't wanked three a day since I was
oh I've done that plenty of times in
hotel rooms of course when you've got
nothing to do well wait as an adult yay
your memory we don't want to no I use
porn I'm not like a [__] animal
they just sit there reminiscing yeah
the break between sessions that doesn't
take long you know what you've never had
sex like twice in an hour no what's your
refractory period none 24 hours really
I'm like one of those muskets oh it
takes it takes a long time to load yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not I don't
know I don't have a modern pistol so
it's like it takes me a lot I got a lot
of bullets but I only got one magazine
what's your perfect meal
ah I have a few of the man I got a
breakfast lunch and dinner
me into a cat string bean I tell you I
got it bad baby that is bad I love it
all your voice is funnier with the worst
posture you have
as you have to be upside down in a
minute
I have sober friend and I'm always like
well I drink but I can always uh get my
[__] done he's like you're justifying
yeah it's like a sober thing that he
always calls me out on like ah get
everything done and then I drink and
he's like yeah yeah I'm like I don't
really get that hungover and if I do I
push through and he's like you see you
can't stop he's always giving me [__]
same thing with the road like oh that's
you gotta you gotta connect I don't do
those gigs you're like you want to do
that gig would be going up in the city
when we were doing spots it's like you
know I don't want to go to Dangerfield
it's like you're like yeah because you I
mean you can't or you know it's gonna be
hard and so if you're not going to
something that's like hard or like put
pushing yourself working out would be
you're not pushing yourself to a limit
of uncomfortableness then I'd rather go
to Russian than Dangerfield yeah yeah
that was a pretty rough road it's the
same way
that was a uh that was a tough room that
was I remember the Velvet seats and the
uh bridge and tunnel I remember they
would they would have you do 25 minutes
in there yes and then they the host
would often forget so you're doing like
30 you end up doing like 32. right
there's like eight people in there I
can't wait to get off you're like where
is that guy dude I was dying because I
remember going at first like 25 minutes
do you know you know how much work I'm
gonna get done in here and then I just
be bombing for 25 minutes yes I remember
one time there was eight people in there
I watched three people they get walked
in to sit down during my set and they
said they give it like one joke and
they're just like and they just walked
out just a humiliating you're doing a
long enough time that they think about
it and leave and it's just one comment
they book a flight to Cleveland that
that club had a grand piano on stage and
by the end of the set like you know you
start by standing next to it then you
put an elbow on it and you're bombing so
much by the end of it you're like
we should show Bert to the [__] oh
that guy
let's say it's right there it's the
first thing it's first thing yeah yeah
no we're not heading McDonald's yep
another McDonald's James Austin black
it's this yeah this guy's so funny I've
been having a lot of sexual escapades as
a you know like having a little
adventures with some freaky Chicago
girls and I've come to the realization
I've been talking to one that I don't
think pegging is necessarily that gay
[Music]
I've watched it 10 times
that is that is Led Zeppelin four
times I guess you can see it from the
beginning I
don't think pegging is necessary
[Laughter]
oh
yeah
I got a little adventures with some
freaky Chicago girls and I've come to
the realization when I'm talking to one
that I don't think pegging is
necessarily that gay
buddies
[__]
the timing
what a line what a line to fall of and
not get to
resolved good night everybody
it's a line that your next line is
supposed to be now hear me out hear me
out and now time for some podcasting
stats from the month of February to end
this video Joe deroza made the most
guest appearances last month going on a
total of five different podcasts
including take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman Matt and Shane secret podcast
Dr Drew after dark and more there was a
three-way tie for the most viewed
episode of the month that came down to
Dave Portnoy on this past weekend Ralph
Barbosa on flagrant and yomi park on
flagrant with all three videos currently
sitting at 1.4 million views each all
also if you haven't watched our
interview with Chris De Stefano yet
it'll be linked on the end screen after
this video so please check that out if
you have nothing to do after this you're
already on YouTube maybe check it out
thank you for watching this video so
much we'll be back Monday with some more
comedy news make sure to subscribe if
you want to join the fastest growing
community of Comedy fans anywhere on the
internet right here on joke world that's
it
[Music]
foreign